[Laughter]
it's complete Bliss true Thompson
clearly feeling the Christmas spirit and
it looks like she's also had a visit
from the Tooth Fairy do you want to say
that you lost your tooth show yourself I
lost my toe I lost my teeth I lost my
toe your toe everyone but I am so
obsessed with her and I love it so much
Khloe Kardashian and her daughter true
spreading Christmas Joy on Instagram and
true blessing us with her vocals do you
like your hat
oh
see
Merry Christmas everyone hello Santa
do you want to be Santa or you're Mrs
Claus oh we all want to be cute over
here okay
let's go have fun in the show we're
gonna do another one
looks like someone's been practicing
their Zen with Mom
beautiful
do you want to say that you lost your
tooth okay show yourself I lost my toe I
lost my teeth I lost my toe you're tall
everyone
after the Cutie showed off her missing
tooth she also shared a sweet
affirmation
peace began with me yeah peace does
begin with you
it's a it's a beautiful thing the
adorable moment comes as Chloe's getting
ready for the holidays with a new
addition to her family a baby boy who
Chloe welcomed back in July via
surrogate with her ex Tristan Thompson
fans of the Kardashians watched it all
play out during the season 2 premiere of
the reality show
[Music]
is such a beautiful gift that we're able
to have all right how does it feel to be
a mom of two well it's about two hours
in
so far it's going good he's perfect oh
thank you he looks just like true wow
we've yet to see the baby's face or
learn his name Chloe shared a rare look
at her baby boy alongside big sister
true in a Halloween post
and then a second snap there's a glimpse
of his itty-bitty foot and Tiny sneaker
we had great Instagram shots in August
the source so ET that true is loving
every moment about being a big sister
and wants to be a mini Mommy to the baby
with a Second Source telling ET quote
she's obsessed with her little brother
Chloe says she's even given him a
nickname my daughter says his name is
snowy and oh your daughter it's not
snowy so that's the hit I swear she just
does things to sort of like mess with me
but his name is not snowy
foreign